control
come in
i found the ancient site
marine
uh
no
negative
i mean oh wlf specialist
oh sorry uh
you just look a lot like my old partner
like exactly like him yeah i could say
the same about you
that planet hopping rastafarian makes
spaceship decoy out of my partner's
skull spine
yeah i've had my fair share of
extraterrestrial run-ins it's my chest
look it's been hurting me all morning
i
just need some gauze you'll walk it off
[Music]
what happens when you cross an 80s movie
with muscular wisecracking soldiers
being killed by a cunning hunter from
space
with
that same thing but the alien has a
laser and power armor a hell of a good
time alien and predator are two of the
coolest and most memorable inventions of
the 70s and 80s and shared a very
similar vibe but they also had a cool
contrast one species is frightening
because of its fascinating simplicity
and animalistic rage that could humble
even the most confident of
technology-reliant space marines while
the other is so advanced and intelligent
that humankind is nothing more than a
big game for it to hunt as a hobby but
both made a career of having gun-toting
badasses quaking in their boots
also they're kind of both allegories for
like vietnam or something it all started
with the fantastic comic depicting a
story where young predators would seed
primitive worlds with aliens to create
new hunting ground and test their metal
further fuel was thrown on the fire with
this cool easter egg in the second
predator movie and from there it was
generally accepted that these two famous
movie monsters can and probably have
bumped into each other at some point
eventually their first major battle
outside of the comics and fan
speculation took place in the world of
video games there are so many alien and
predator crossover games that it's
become a franchise all its own that for
a time was just as popular as the
individual series it spawned from
there's so many of these games that it
wouldn't make sense to include them in a
review of either solo series actually
take it away unscripted live stream
xavier alright
i would like to rant for a second every
goddamn [ __ ] in the history of the
universe commented on both our videos
how could you leave out avp 2010 how
could you leave out avp 1999 how do you
leave a avp extension well okay which
video would they go in if we do one or
the other
if it's the alien video or predator
video where is avp go
naturally you think by the virtue of the
fact that there's like [ __ ] 15 of
them that they would be there on video
god damn
so why didn't you guys cover alien vs
predator the arcade game
he's angry and with that we're going to
take a look at all the clashes these two
legendary beasts have had in the world
of pixelated blood to see which one was
the best one
so owlf what's that all about
all four life forms baby that's perfect
so you know about the wet skeleton penis
monsters penis-shaped monsters
no i know but the vagina face monsters
what the hell are you talking about oh
they're the worst just big skeletal
freudian nightmares that stick you to
the walls and kill off major characters
between sequels
wait a minute
that does sound familiar
that sounds like the other life form the
owls detailed in those files
all right listen up these bastards have
been at this pissing contest for
centuries
[Music]
hey let's see what we're really up
against
[Laughter]
[Music]
avp arcade it's like double dragon
except the enemies look more like the
type of dragon you get in the mail in a
very discreetly unmarked box that you
don't want your family to see released
in 1994 and developed by capcom avp
arcade starts with two hilariously
proportioned street fighter characters
being overwhelmed by aliens in an island
city on the west side when suddenly
they're miraculously saved by a bunch of
heroic good guys that have never done
anything morally questionable in the
name of their culture or to heighten
their social status among their alien
peers
[Music]
in this multiplayer co-op beat em up you
play as a selection of two cool space
marines that look like walking action
figures and neato friend predators like
my main man [ __ ] hunter this guy is
supposed to be a cyborg version of major
dutch schaefer from the original
predator movie
while those body proportions are only
slightly exaggerated from the real
arnold i do wonder why he has a rocket
launching robot arm the gameplay is your
typical beat em up with special combos
and moves for every fighter some have
more range some do more damage and some
are faster everyone's got a nice skill
and moves to balance out the co-op
gameplay along the way you encounter a
lot of enemy variety i like how the
predators can pick up and use the
marines pulse rifles too you go through
various stages either solo or with a
friend to button mash thousands of
aliens to death you even get a boss
fight with a few evil predators and some
fights with human soldiers there's even
a section where you ride on top of a
moving troop carrier like the alien
arcade game eventually after battering
so many zenos your knuckles go numb we
discover that the invasion was
orchestrated by none other than evil
space conglomerate weyland yutani who
appear to be behind every sinister act
committed in this fictional universe
including but not limited to space world
war 3 space ebola and space socks with
sandals together your team of heroes
crash a spaceship into the island full
of aliens and miraculously stop them
from eradicating the human race but why
did you help us prattlers
because you helped me once
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus [ __ ] christ is
i heard that this game was intended to
be a tie-in for an avp movie in the 90s
but much like freddy vs jason we saw how
that worked out it took a while
check this one out if you're looking for
something a little more simple to play
with friends
and if you can actually figure out how
to get the emulator working for it
making its mark as the first video game
to bring this feud to home consoles is
alien versus predator on the super
nintendo developed by jorydon and
released to north america in september
of 1993. we take control of the predator
after receiving a distress call from the
planet vega 4 where a group of miners
discover a colony of xenomorphs living
deep on the ground and well
let's just say they didn't exactly
strike gold but the predator sure did
they were planning on hunting measly old
humans but after finding out about the
xenomorph's discovery they're going
after the bigger game imagine being the
humans in this scenario you either get
hunted down by the predators like fish
in a barrel or discover a much deadlier
species to distract the predators with
that'll just tear your face to shreds
anyway
man we really do just suck don't we
game play is in the style of the simple
side-scrolling beat-em-up genre that
took the 90s by storm you'll duke it up
with waves of xenomorphs across a
variety of stages each ending with a
unique boss fight against a special
breed of xenomorphs they all have
different characteristics since they've
been gestated in different animals i
always enjoy this concept it's an
obvious way of having different enemy
types and it's fun to see variants of
the classic xeno plus we don't have to
keep going through the same boss fight
against an alien queen oh wait this game
has that too even though this game has
really basic mechanics it still manages
to let the player use a good amount of
the predator's iconic weapons you can
use his plasma caster for ranged attacks
and even charge it up to a special move
that calls upon some sort of orbital
strike that does damage to everyone on
screen even the predator himself most of
the weapons like the smartdisk combi
stick and cloaking device come in the
form of pickups dropped by the alien
the [ __ ] thieves
after defeating the alien queen the
predator is deemed a hero for
single-handedly wiping out the galaxy of
one of the deadliest species responding
to our universe
but the predator does not care for
thanks
he'll just come back and rip your
[ __ ] spine out when he gets too bored
a couple of months later the game boy
version was released despite sharing the
same cover this is an entirely different
game having more in common with a
metroidvania side scroller rather than a
simple beat em up
combat takes a back seat the predator
has one simple melee attack classic
predator weapons are available to you
but i never found much use for them this
game is more focused on navigating the
map to track down a key that'll open the
door at the end of the level
along the way you'll encounter brick
walls that you have to blow up using
bombs found in the level it's important
that you don't accidentally use a bomb
when it's not needed because there are a
limited number of them found in the
level and you'll end up blocking
yourself out of progression
genius game design there
and that's as far as the metroidvania
elements go while there are hints of
them it doesn't fully commit to the idea
the bombs are the only integral piece of
equipment needed to progress i think it
would have been cool if the predator was
stripped of his weapons at the start of
the game picking them up along your
journey and being decked out by the end
of the game ready to face off against
the alien queen weapons and gadgets
could have also been implemented into
environmental puzzles like using the
cloaking device to get past lasers the
plasma caster to hit distant switches
and the smartthis to hit targets in
sequential order this game makes the
interesting choice of squeezing in a map
into the main gameplay screen i played
this on an emulator where i had the
ability to expand the image into full
screen so i didn't have a problem
reading the map but [ __ ]
i can't imagine how little timmy back in
the day was able to make do with all of
this crammed into a small dark game boy
screen the story is nothing we've never
seen before predators place alien eggs
on the planet to set up a big hunting
party they underestimate the xenomorphs
and their clan is almost completely
wiped out leaving you as the sole
survivor eventually you face off against
an alien queen in a less than stellar
boss fight an adp metroidvania game is
an interesting idea
sadly it's never used to its full
potential once you play one level you've
kind of played them all frustrating
design choices like having the map be
tied to an energy meter that
continuously decreases eventually
leaving you with no map at all and
levels that are confusing enough to
navigate
that combined with the predator
snail-like pace and uninteresting combat
makes this one hard to recommend
i think i've seen this in those files
this is ancient technology beyond our
comprehension
you sure you should be doing that who
knows what kind of poorly lit
shenanigans could ensue how else are we
supposed to learn a way to defeat them
we have to try
oh [ __ ] never
mind i think the hunt has just begun
[Music]
remember the atari jaguar
no i don't blame you in the early 90s
atari was to make a triumphant return
with a new console the ferocious atari
jaguar the 64-bit beast to shake the
grounds of the video game landscape
64 bits
that's like
more than that
unfortunately it's not just bits and
other combinations of letters and
numbers that don't make any sense to me
that make the console it's about the
games baby okay okay
let me ask you a question
how many games does this atari jaguar
system have my friend atari is the game
master they've got enough games to keep
your fragile little mind occupied until
the next millennium yeah like what [ __ ]
the toilet bowl console's lackluster
library couldn't compete with the likes
of the sega saturn super nintendo and
sony playstation but there was one title
that to this day
many still claim is worth owning a
jaguar for
one game that it's alien versus predator
what did you think i was gonna say
trevor mcfur in the crescent galaxy
the hell is going on here
shield your eyes kids aliens vs predator
was released in 1994 and developed by
rebellion whom would go on to be our
pseudo-designated developers for avp
games
after having a couple of beat-em-ups avp
for the jaguar is a doom-style
first-person shooter and more
importantly the first adp game to
feature three separate campaigns one for
the marine one for the xenomorph and one
for the predator
which would become a staple for these
games
each campaign features unique gameplay
mechanics and narrative suitable for the
character by the way the proper order to
play an adp game is by starting with the
marine followed by the alien and lastly
the predator that is law and i will not
have it any other way in the marine
campaign we step into the boots of
private lance j lewis who's been serving
a cryo sentence for [ __ ] slapping a
superior officer i like him already he
wakes up to find that the ship's crew
has been massacred leaving him as the
sole survivor for a game of its time avp
does an impressive job of instilling a
feeling of isolation the marine campaign
is devoid of any other human npcs that
aren't dead on the floor at least
there's no music either only the low hum
of the ship's electrical workings making
the moments when xenomorphs jump you
from behind or corner you in a vent
shaft that much more thrilling
[Music]
at face value it's easy to make
comparisons to doom or castle
wolfenstein this game adapts to
graphical style of 2d character sprites
within the 3d environment especially
when looking at the marine gameplay
since he's the only character that
wields weapons like a shotgun and a
pulse rifle
but the comparisons pretty much end
there while doom is more focused on
fast-paced action and keeping a forward
momentum the marine campaign is much
slower there's a strong emphasis on
exploration and survival ammo and health
items are limited so it goes without
saying that being careless is an easy
way to find yourself in a bind your main
objective is to activate the ship's
self-destruct system and getting your
ass out of there in an escape pod along
the way you'll come across locked doors
that require a certain level of
clearance and you won't be able to
progress until you find the
corresponding key card that's all well
and good some good old-fashioned
backtracking and exploration
the only problem being that that's
easier said than done since navigating
the spaceship is damn near impossible
when everything looks the same it's
really easy to get turned around in
these environments with branching
hallways that spiral into each other and
don't have recognizable landmarks that
help keep track of your position in the
level things get even more confusing
when you throw in sub levels and vent
shafts that don't make it clear where
you'll end up the game provides a map
but even then i didn't find it to be
much help i always use the resident evil
games as a prime example when talking
about exploration and backtracking done
well
it's important to have distinct rooms
and hallways that way the player can
easily paint a mental map and
effortlessly navigate the world on top
of that resident evil provides a map
that's super easy to read if need be my
experience with the marine campaign
boiled down to aimlessly wandering
around shooting aliens and burning my
feet on their acid blood until i bumped
into a predator and got turned into a
not so impressive trophy i'd say that's
a pretty successful run moving on
as the alien you have one simple task
protect the alien queen at all cost the
core gameplay loop of exploring the
spaceship and its sub-levels remains the
same so unfortunately all the campaigns
suffer from the same problem of having
to navigate confusing environments
one difference being that aliens can
only access other floors through vent
shafts
because they can't figure out buttons
hey that's not accurate to the movies
the standout feature in the alien
campaign is its respawning mechanic the
xenomorph has no way of regaining health
but you have the ability to cocoon
marines if you do so when you die it
won't simply be game over instead you'll
respawn on the last marine you cocooned
that's a really cool mechanic that goes
perfectly with the concept of the aliens
not only is the alien's basic instinct
to impregnate anything with a heartbeat
but taking control of another alien
after dying plays into the aspect that
you're part of a hive mind that's
working together i would have liked to
see more avp games adapt this idea
rather than implementing traditional
checkpoints and manual saves the biggest
drawback of this feature however is that
if you make substantial progress and go
a while without cocooning a marine if
you die it's possible that the last
marine cocoon was way back now you have
to once again make your way through the
maze that this spaceship is
but at least you won't have to deal with
the marines you already killed my
experience with the xenomorph campaign
boiled down to aimlessly wandering
around slapping and chomping marines
until i bumped into a predator and was
turned into a not so impressive trophy
i'm sensing a pattern here the predator
has the most versatile gameplay we start
our mission in the predator ship which
just looks hideous i mean it's accurate
to how it looks in predator 2 with its
orange tinge but it doesn't translate
all that well here i forgot to mention
that each character has a different hud
representing different abilities and
weapons that your character has
you'd be forgiving for not noticing it
here because the devs decided to go with
an orange overlay for the predator and
with this campaign starting in an orange
environment it's pretty tough to see my
equipment and health when it's orange on
orange orange you glad i pointed that
out as a predator your mission is to
hunt down the alien queen
you have access to the classic weapons
you'd expect except you don't get them
in a conventional manner the predator
campaign has what is called the honor
point system your score depends on how
you kill your enemies killing them while
visible will increase your score thus
giving you access to more weapons
killing while cloaked will take away
points and if you go below a certain
threshold you can lose those weapons hey
wait a minute that isn't accurate to the
movies if that's the case then these
guys are the biggest dishonorable
scumbags i've seen look at him
pathetic in all seriousness i think this
is an interesting system weighing the
benefits of staying safe behind your
cloaking ability
or risking exposing yourself and taking
damage to unlock new weapons is engaging
a choice i found odd is that the
predator is able to store med kits he
picks up and use them manually while the
marine is forced to immediately use them
upon pickup with the marine campaign
having more of a survival tone at least
in comparison to the two other campaigns
i think letting the marines stock up on
medkits would have made sense
my experience with the predator campaign
boiled down to aimlessly wandering
around making not so impressive trophies
out of helpless marines until i bumped
into his xenomorph in a marine
together
in the same room
working together
what kind of horseshit is this and i'm
the one being judged on my honor i
thought this was aliens vs predator not
aliens and marines to time the predator
behind his back [ __ ] this i'm out avp on
the atari jaguar has some cool ideas to
make each campaign unique and
representative of each species but the
confusing level layout hold it back
it's a kind of game that's best played
with the strategy guide on hand which
frankly doesn't speak well to a game's
design
so not exactly the killer app i was
expecting for the jaguar
but a commendable foundation for future
avp games
alien vs predator now known as alien vs
predator classic is rebellion's second
attempt at bringing us the long rivalry
between the two famous martians in video
game form but this time it's in fully
realized 3d graphics we're not falling
around anymore i hear a lot of people
talk about this one as the first hit
alien vs predator video game being the
most memorable and setting the bar for
future avp games
so is it as good as everyone remembers
or is it another janky mess that'll make
me castrate myself with a predator smart
disc
sticking with the formula of three
separate campaigns because if it ain't
broke don't fix it you have access to
all the different species from the
get-go so starting with the colonial
marine my first impression with the
marines campaign was that i was
surprised with how fast movement is
i thought my pc was bugging out and
running the game at a higher speed than
it was supposed to i was under the
impression that at least for the marine
campaign this would be a slow paced
survival horror game like the last one
but the action is significantly ramped
up here your choice of weapons will
extend from pulse rifles pistols rocket
launchers flamethrowers many guns and of
course the iconic smart gun which is
just so damn fun to use its cursor will
automatically lock onto any bugs on the
screen making them easy pickings but to
be fair the xenomorphs don't exactly put
up the best fight at times
first off they don't take a lot of
damage short bursts from the pulse rifle
make quick work of them unless you're
facing off against a tougher praetorian
the ai for the zenos can be pretty
janked at times you'll sometimes catch
them running into walls or just kind of
darting around aimlessly their strength
comes from running at you in big numbers
being more derivative of aliens rather
than alien i'm not a big fan of games
that infinitely spawn enemies because i
like to explore and take in the
environment at my own pace and it's kind
of hard to do that when you have to deal
with enemies constantly showing up like
pests when i'm trying to watch a damn
video but it does make it feel like
you're going up against this endless
hive that you don't stand a chance with
by the way sorry there's a lot of green
in my gameplay footage here but the
thing is that this game is dark as all
hell i really like the atmospheric tone
of dimly lit corridors and laboratories
but god damn does it work against you in
a fast-paced shooter where you go up
against multiple enemies at once
you're equipped with an infinite amount
of flares but you can only light up to
four before your first one burns out and
the rest start to follow they illuminate
enough and even though it's a little
immersion breaking i appreciate that you
have an infinite amount of them but
you're also equipped with night vision
goggles which are way more practical and
make flares obsolete so you run into the
problem many of us had with the arkham
games you have these atmospheric
environments with interesting lighting
but they're completely ruined by having
an intensely bright filter that's on
ninety percent of the time
while this game certainly isn't
graphically impressive by today's
standards i think it looked pretty good
given the time it was released character
models are pretty low detail but i've
always been forgiving of polygonal
graphics and it still stands true here
like i said before the atmosphere is
where this game stands the test of time
you'll be exploring recognizable
settings like a rundown colony a
spaceship similar to nostromo and even
the derelict spacecraft that holds the
giant space jockey
however when you're going through these
levels the hallways labs staircases all
start to blend together so it's easy to
get turned around if you don't pay
attention to where you've already been
or what your objective is which brings
me to one of my bigger criticisms of
this game your objectives are given to
you by your commander through these
monitors that you find throughout the
level you really have to pay attention
to these videos because they can hold
vital information that gave you
directions to your next objective
damn do you throw all five switches
main gate hasn't budged
the engineer had one might still be on
it
his body is in med lab on level two got
that level two
you'll also get a quick message at the
top of your screen letting you know what
your task is but once it's gone it's
gone there's no way to look at a mission
log or journal so you might just stand
there with no idea what to do next and
hope that by wandering around you'll
eventually head in the right direction
about those videos that give you your
objectives they're also how most of the
game's story is delivered they're full
motion videos and the actors are clearly
devs who film these in their offices
the acting is pretty bad and they don't
come off as rough and tough military
leaders and more like dorks in cosplay
that being said these videos are
endearing as all hell and with video
games now being the biggest form of
entertainment with ridiculously high
budgets and big name actors becoming
more common in them we don't really get
this kind of thing as much as we used to
you can criticize their acting to hell
them back but what i see is a team
having fun with their project and
pouring their passion into it i know me
and xavier can get behind that fighting
the predators here is pretty
underwhelming just look at my first
encounter with them
[Music]
there's no structure or design to these
fights i would have appreciated if these
were treated as more traditional boss
fights with a proper arena some attack
patterns and maybe some phases the
predators are used sparingly but i hate
that they randomly show up as if they
were a random enemy so these fights are
kind of a wild card they can be pretty
tough and offer a standout moment or
they can be wiped out with little to no
effort there's even a pretty alien that
shows up predating the one we see in avp
requiem but it's treated so
unceremoniously no build up no reveal
it shows up without a moment's notice
and before you know it it's dead on the
ground
the most proper boss fight is the last
one against the alien queen but even
then you don't actually fight it you run
around pressing buttons in the right
sequence to open the hangar door and
suck the queen into the void of space a
cool callback to the movie but
underwhelming and anticlimactic as a
final boss now that we've killed its
mother let's empathize with a xenomorph
and start its campaign
if you thought playing as the marine
felt fast then playing as a xenomorph is
kicking speed into maximum overdrive but
to my surprise i never had a problem
navigating levels even with the
ridiculously fast movement speed of the
xeno you also have the ability to crawl
up walls by holding down the left
trigger if you're playing with a
controller again something that i didn't
have a problem with as ludacris as
crawling up walls and ceilings in the
first person view sounds it must be all
those years of playing spider-man games
you have two forms of attacking swiping
your claws at your enemies or stabbing
them with the end of your tail you can
also use the extra mouth
inside your mouth
is there a word for that
the inner jaw
kinky
you can use that to bite off the head of
an enemy's corpse to replenish health my
initial instinct when playing as a
xenomorph was to play it as a stealth
game you can take out light sources to
create shadows and switch between
different view modes that will allow you
to see in the dark and highlight enemies
however this gameplay approach would
prove to be more difficult than i
expected the enemy's ai placement and
patrol pattern don't exactly support a
stealth approach it can be done but i
was mowed down by enemies often instead
i think the game wants you to play as an
unstoppable fast and furious constantly
moving force of nature swiping enemies
heads off before they even see you
coming and that's totally in line with
how the alien acts in the movies but so
is a stealth approach and i think
leaning into that playstyle would have
made the alien campaign unique and
different from the other two out of all
the campaigns the xenos was my least
favorite the game wants you to feel like
a ferocious unstoppable killing machine
but i never did and that's due to how
easy it is for your enemies to shoot you
down i felt so fragile as the xenomorph
that i would cower at the presence of a
single enemy you can die with just a
couple shots put into you with just
about any weapon i never felt like the
perfect organism more like the subpar
beta virgin specimen the alien story
doesn't have a whole lot of substance it
starts off with you protecting the hive
from marines than just killing killing
and more killing until you board a ship
that's heading to earth along the way
you get a grand total of two encounters
with a predator and man i didn't expect
fighting predators to get much worse
than it was in the marines campaign
as the alien you obviously have no means
of weaponry or any form of projectiles
for that matter so fighting the predator
sums up to awkwardly jumping around it
while you wildly flail your arms or tail
hoping that you land the hit as you try
to avoid his shoulder cannon i can only
imagine how silly this must look from an
outsider's perspective
i think limiting the predator to his
melee based weapons like his wrist
blades and combi stick would have
resulted in a better fight between the
two or maybe having the fight take place
in an arena that allows for you to flank
and sneak up on him and with every
successful hit you eliminate another
weapon or gadget from the predator's
arsenal similar to the boss fight
against mr freeze in arkham city and
with that we have yet another
underwhelming final boss alright now
let's jump into the predator campaign
as a predator you have the most varied
selection of weapons to choose from you
have access to his wrist blades smart
discs shoulder cannon plasma pistol and
a spear gun and they're all useful some
weapons are tied to this blue energy
meter but it can be replenished with
pickups from throughout the levels
switching between vision modes will
allow you to autolock to different enemy
types thermal vision for human enemies
and whatever this red vision is called
for aliens this has to be my favorite
weapon in the whole game but pulling off
headshots with the speargun is also
pretty damn satisfying
what's completely useless is the
predator's cloak ability i can't tell
what the rules for it are regarding how
the enemy ai reacts to it sometimes it
seems to work and sometimes it doesn't
i'll have it activated and an enemy from
way across the room will spot me other
times i'll be a couple feet away from an
enemy and he'll be oblivious to my
presence i couldn't tell if it was based
on movement sound or lighting i
understand that in lore the predator's
camouflage isn't perfect it is visible
to the human eye if you spot a shimmer
or light being bent and distorted
but when transferring that concept to a
video game i think there needs to be a
system that lets the player know how the
enemy is reacting to your presence
before they're fully alert and attacking
you without that trying to take a
stealthy approach would result in a lot
of frustration
and it will make any gadgets or
mechanics that are meant for stealth
feel like an afterthought i ended up
ignoring the predator's cloak ability
for the majority of his campaign and
focused on making my presence known and
feared with the use of all my weapons
the predator also has the most varied
set of levels offering different vistas
like a jungle setting a military base a
cavern and even the prison planet
fiorona from alien 3 and you'll find
some platforming elements within them
which was a nice change of pace
this one was my favorite campaign of the
three feeling fresh throughout its
entire run and having the best weapons
to play around with now let's see if i
can bring it home with an awesome final
boss fight against the alien queen
why is it so hard to have a good boss
fight in this game avp classic may not
be the legendary game some fans make it
out to be but it's a solid title maybe
some of its ideas can be refined and
made into something outstanding with a
sequel
and the sequel we received this time
with monolith productions taking the
helm avb-2 was released in october of
2001. i'd say this is an overall
improvement over the original we now
have fully animated cutscenes with
decent voice acting once again you have
three separate campaigns to play through
this time with intertwining storylines
you revisit levels from different
perspectives and see what the supporting
cast was up to at different points in
time stop me if you've heard this one
before a platoon of colonial marines
receive a distress signal from a
research complex where a different squad
of marines have gone missing you land
there only to find out the place has
been infested by xenomorphs and the
usual escapades ensue you also have this
kylo ren looking [ __ ] with a
hard-on for xenomorph preservation man
playing an avp game would make for a fun
drinking game take a drink every time
you come across any of these the marine
campaign is a standout here in my
opinion it takes his time building
suspense you don't encounter an enemy
until the second level and it's really
effective the alien campaign is more of
the same from the first game but the
opening is really fun and creative
because it starts you off at the
beginning of its life cycle hatching
from an egg as a facehugger you must
sneak around and find a host to
impregnate once you do you even get to
chew your way out of the guy's chest
cavity as a chestburster that's just
awesome after that you have to find
enough protein to consume to allow
yourself to grow into the xenomorph
drone we all know and love the predator
campaign has you play as a youngblood i
like that you're granted more weapons
from the elders as you progress proving
yourself as a worthy hunter i think the
campaigns here are more competently
designed because they have a better idea
of what they want to be but man this
game gets unbearably hard at times there
are some boss fights that are straight
up broken the only way i beat them was
by either getting lucky with the boss
glitching out and just standing there or
by using the noclip command i don't know
if this game is bugged out because i had
to download it from an abandonware
website it's not available on steam or
any other console but if that's not the
case i don't know how anyone beat these
bosses back in the day you can only take
like two hits before you drop dead
meanwhile these guys are built like
tanks look at this i'm cheating and i'm
still intimidated if you ever want to
play avp2 well first of all good luck
cause this thing is a pain in the ass to
download on a pc but once you do make
sure you play it on easy i went through
the three campaigns on normal and i
found it to be unplayable at times due
to his difficulty this game did get an
expansion that i didn't even attempt to
get running on this already shoddy
version of avp2 so we'll have xavier go
over the concept of the expansion and
see if it adds anything interesting take
it away old chum
a neat continuation of avp2 is the
primal hunt expansion it's like a dlc
but no one's internet was good enough at
the time so it was missing that sweet
delicious d
so now it's just content in disc form i
miss when content was in pog form primal
hunt sets up several plot points of the
main game by showing the backstory of
predators on
lv1201070 hard to keep track of all of
these i wish they had proper names
the main playable alien character is a
pred alien which predates the movie's
predilection for predetermined
predicaments predicted by predator
predecessors and predominantly
predisposed piedeters although the
gameplay is basically identical to
playing as a bog standard human hybrid
xenomorph
you just see some mandibles on your
screen if you take a bite out of crime
is the pred alien the most legendarily
underutilized and poorly implemented
potentially cool concept in all of
fiction
save for boba fett for 40 years except
even he got a shining moment eventually
this over designed sack of ass hasn't
done a single worthwhile thing since it
was conceptualized by some creative
goomba in the 90s i like this cool part
in the cave where the rocks look like a
xenomorph head from a specific angle i
don't know if that was intentional or
not but i thought it was worth noting
the story goes that 500 years before the
start of the main game a battle between
preds and aliens was halted by
accidentally putting everyone in stasis
only for them to be unleashed when the
human characters bungle their way in if
you like the main game you'll probably
dig this too
a series known for high octane and up
close and personal battles and tight
corridors and claustrophobic wooded
scenery stealthy creatures that sneak up
on their prey from behind to pull them
into trees and cramped ventilation
shafts scenarios where massive groups of
soldiers are whittled down one by one by
an intelligent enemy force they greatly
outnumber yeah this gameplay formula
represents that well
avp extinct hole is the real time
stratego simulator a real time
with a relevant attention seeker bill
maher
a real time
stretch strategy game where low poly
models of three factions stand on top of
each other in team formations that
require a lot of clipping what's the
story for this game
marines go to planet lv [ __ ] whatever
and find a hive of aliens then try to
fight them then young blood predators
show up and get involved by hunting the
other two things running around killing
each other that's only the plot of every
avp thing ever i could probably just
copy and paste that into a bunch of
other reviews here ironically this is
one of the very few games on this list
that i can actually play myself without
emulating but i can't find a copy and
also i'm not really a big fan of this
style of game sorry halo wars and
risk factions i guess
i'll have to sit this one out and pass
it off to diego say something nice about
this game in the first sentence i dare
you
okay how about this as a newcomer to
this genre avp extinction does a good
job of explaining how the game works
this game's tutorial is a must it's
narrated by this super monotone voice
guide that sounds like he'd rather be
doing literally anything else in the
world his lack of enthusiasm makes
jumping into this game kind of
intimidating and it makes me feel like
i'm watching an instructional video on
how to put together a sink or something
this tutorial will teach you the basics
of playing aliens vs predator extinction
please note that you can press start at
any time to pause the tutorial and see
your current task
but following the tutorials and learning
the mechanics wasn't an issue i was also
surprised with how well the game
controls on a dualshock 2. i know rts
games are usually more associated with
pcs but i think the guys at zono did a
good job at bringing this genre to the
ps2 and making it approachable to
newcomers not to say they were the first
to do it but it was my first time
playing a game like this
with all that said i don't think avp
extinction will be the game to make me a
fan of rts games i get frustrated with
the lack of control i have when playing
these games i feel like a babysitter
watching over 20 kids that refuse to
listen to me too often i will give my
squad a waypoint to follow only for me
to turn away for two seconds and find
one of the marines straying off into
their own path
you're supposed to be a
unit my unit
squads will stupidly walk into
mountainsides if you set a waypoint
that's too far they're not smart enough
to follow a clear route that will lead
to your waypoints so you have to hold
their hands every step of the way and
set waypoints just a few feet from one
another i also get panic when my squad
is jumped by a group of enemies and i
can't directly get involved all i can do
is watch helplessly as my children get
slaughtered
i'm sorry my hideous killer space bugs
i'm a terrible parent
i just don't have the patience for this
game a lot of the time you're just
sitting there waiting for stuff to
finish wait for the marines to finish
repairing this device wait for the medic
to patch up your troops wait for the
xenomorphs to drag body to the queen's
nest how does anyone ever achieve these
timed bonus objectives
i have to say that i think it's cool
that each campaign still manages to
encapsulate a theme representative of
each species for example the marine
campaign has an emphasis on having a
strong army comprised of various roles
like your typical infantry units a medic
sniper and a technician
having a balanced team is key to survive
the onslaught of aliens and predators
you'll be facing
the alien campaign is all about
reproduction dragging any life form you
can find back to your nest for
facehuggers to use as host
different hosts result in different
kinds of xenomorphs like drones or
runners the mechanics go deep into how
the xenomorph biology works
predators are about gaining honor points
by claiming the skull of your falling
prey to then spend on armor upgrades and
more advanced weapons it was interesting
trying out this genre for the first time
through an ip i'm a big fan of but i
don't think avp is right for this kind
of game when i think avp i don't think
large scale wars and a wide landscape
predators are scary because just one of
them is a massive threat being a marine
in these situations is scary because
usually you're alone or at most with a
small group trying to survive
insurmountable odds not because you have
30 other soldiers backing you up you
might have something there with the
xenomorph's perspective being the
overseer among a large number of aliens
is an effective way of representing the
hive mind concept but again i'd rather
take direct control of xenomorph or
going against them right there in the
heat of the action
i don't want to judge the game too
harshly because the genre is not for me
but i'd love to hear what an rts
connoisseur thinks of this one
i can't see [ __ ] down here am i supposed
to enjoy the spooky monsters like this
huh
every room in the pyramid must represent
a new challenge
if we figure out what we have to do here
we might be able to move on to the next
room
that's a lot of blind assumptions based
on some hieroglyphs in a dark room
i'm desperate enough man just light the
way with muzzle flashes
hey did you hear something
rebellion once again takes another crack
at developing an avp game with 2007's
psp exclusive avp requiem can it make up
for the unwatchable not just because it
stinks but i literally can't see what's
happening on screen wreck that was the
movie of the same name
oh you optimistic young buck you
avpr loosely adapts the events of the
movie our story begins when a predator
ship carrying face huggers crash lands
onto the humble town of gunnison
colorado with these critters now on the
loose we have a slew of problems on our
reptilian hands this time around we can
only play as a predator our mission is
to eradicate all of the xenomorphs gone
rampant and any evidence of extra to
rest your life including the crash
predator ship and any loose parts so
your first objective is to make contact
with the crash site and blow the ship to
kingdom come
once that's out of the way we go through
an assortment of levels versing these
aliens
what we have here is one of those games
that throws a bunch of [ __ ] at the wall
and doesn't do any of those things
exceptionally well
it's a third person action game with a
little bit of stealth some platforming
puzzles and a simple progression system
with combat being one of the pillar
gameplay elements it sadly leaves a lot
to be desired it controls just fine and
isn't clunky or anything like that i was
pleasantly surprised with how well
controls were mapped onto the psp
something the system struggled with when
it came to controlling the camera in 3d
action games but that was never an issue
the lock-on system works perfectly and
snapping the camera behind the predator
by pressing both trigger buttons is
nifty the problem is that combat just
feels shallow and lacks that intensity
you would find in a concrete jungle or
hunting grounds the honor system makes a
return and once again it's used to
unlock weapons from the predator's
arsenal tagging enemies before killing
them will reward you points and killing
innocent civilians will penalize you the
predator has never reached hero status
but i can appreciate him showing some
mercy to helpless humans when he's meant
to be your protagonist having different
predator weapons at your disposal is
always cool but i felt like i could have
kept the same loadout throughout the
entirety of the game and i wouldn't be
missing out on anything special while it
doesn't do anything outstanding i think
the biggest strength of this game is its
level design there's a good variety of
locales here like the sewers a cemetery
a school and a hospital oh hey it's
those iconic set pieces from the movie
for the most part levels are linear but
occasionally they would open up with
optional paths that lead you to some
collectibles i really dig the idea of
facehugger husks being this game's
collectibles it's a clever way of
incorporating a classic gameplay element
into the game's narrative switching to a
particular vision mode in the biomass
will highlight the facehuggers and the
environment however that's made
completely obsolete when the game
straight up marks them on your map
a nonsensical decision if you ask me
there's a charming simplicity to these
levels that never makes the game
offensive but by the same token it's
also the game's biggest setback the
issue is that from beginning to end the
experience is one big lull there aren't
any revelations or curveballs that keep
things interesting there's a strong lack
of enemy variety ninety percent of the
time you're fighting stander xenomorphs
at one point it seems like they're
setting up the dog alien hybrids from
alien 3. when you find what i guess is
supposed to be a dog
its chest is burst open but the embryo
matures into a regular old xenomorph you
do get to fight praetorians and they
take significantly more damage but three
enemy types just isn't enough no boss
fights either actually there is one
final boss i'll give you three guesses
as to who it is an alien queen
good guess but no she's killed in a
cutscene
maybe a souped-up marine in an exosuit
a pretty alien logical but nope
it's against the helicopter
that's right these sons of [ __ ]
pulled a the division on us and made a
damn copter the one and only boss
you know what
maybe maybe it's a pretty alien paddling
the helicopter right
right
what baffles me is that rebellion had
full access to the complete script of
the movie and even an early cut of the
movie before its release why not include
what's arguably the coolest part of the
movie well according to an interview by
cam shia from ign of tim jones head
designer rebellion when asked about how
the game ties into the film he stated we
had to work within strict confines to
remain consistent with the movie and
everything we did had to be approved by
the studio there are also some key
strong differences between our game and
the movie because fox didn't want the
entire plot given away before people see
the film at the cinema
okay so avp requiem the game released on
november 13 2007
avp requiem the movie released on
december 25th 2007. merry freaking
christmas hope you weren't naughty that
year i i understand not wanting to spoil
the movie ahead of its release but
why not wait the extra month and release
it alongside the movie give yourself the
extra month for polish and more
importantly you get to have the print
alien in your game about the movie that
has the freaking pred alien in it and
fox why are you being so protective over
adp requiem like it's freaking citizen
kane it's aliens versus predator it's a
silly movie and now you have a silly
game they both suck congratulations
holy fish paste shut it off me get it
hey you know that annoying thing where a
series gets a new installment after a
long time gap between sequels and the
new one doesn't have a number or
subtitle well here's aliens vs predator
which is like the sixth or seventh game
to have that title [ __ ] me so this game
once again has three campaigns that are
all fairly short but make up for it when
you add them all up one is a rookie
space marine whose face you only see a
few times near the ending
a young predator eager to wet his claws
with the blood of dangerous prey and a
xenomorph who likes killing things
because that's all these silly double
mouth things are good for let's take
them one at a time
doomed marine
so our story begins with carl bishop
weyland the guy from the avp movie
somehow alive again after hundreds of
years and a slight spelling error on his
driver's license entering a buried
pyramid on an alien world not unlike the
one we saw in the film this causes some
hijinks when his weyland yutani workers
end up unleashing the horde of aliens
while trying to breed them for
bioweapons
and opening the pyramid has also alerted
a group of predators to come by and jump
in for an impromptu hunting trip while
on the way back from an intergalactic
booze run during space mardi gras and
both of these hijinks cause even more
hijinks when one of the weyland workers
calls in the space marines to come in
and fumble the space football at every
turn
as they're known to do
might as well mod this game so these
guys are stormtroopers as the marine you
fight your way through aliens upon
aliens upon aliens upon a encounter a
single predator and kick his ass in like
two minutes and then encounter some more
aliens
this is basically an early version of
colonial marines with a special cameo
from a predator halfway through the game
except unlike colonial marines this game
is functional without two years of
patches and it's kind of fun and knows
how to build tension and isn't hideous
to look at
while colonial marines came out three
years after this it feels like it came
six years before this avp 2010 knows how
to pace out its action with some slower
moments to explore and build tension and
jump at shadows for a bit
sometimes you're just exploring
environments and finding audio logs in
the dark by yourself and it's unnerving
and spooky instead of just constant
jittering noises and screaming using the
pulse rifle and other guns from the
space marine arsenal doesn't feel as
shaky and weird and still has this
panicky feeling because the enemies take
a lot of damage before going down
without feeling too spongy you really
get a sense that the aliens are stronger
than you because of how much more
punishment they can take from your
superior firepower which was a great
decision for making sure they didn't
feel like weak cannon fodder
any individual xenomorph can be a
serious threat and a crowd of them is
pretty anxiety inducing you always have
to keep moving and stay one step ahead
of them to make sure you don't get
flanked or ganged up on this combat
really works for an aliens fps game but
i haven't played any others beyond
colonial marines so i can't compare that
much the characters on the radio
pressure you to hurry up towards
objectives so often without realizing
what the [ __ ] you're going through [ __ ]
these hostile space animals are covered
in armor-piercing bladed weapons and
have acid for blood and take like 30
shots to go down do not tell me to hurry
up i have problems out here there's a
little bit of gun play against military
androids near the end of the game they
feel like bullet sponges in like an
annoying way where their bodies are
heavily armored and you need to aim at
their limbs to really do anything and it
just takes forever
your guns aren't that precise and even
if you kneecap the androids they still
keep shooting at you so you have to keep
pumping them full of ammo only for them
to explode a short while later when you
thought they were finally dead they also
have a tendency to kill you in two hits
if you get too close to them they're
just really annoying and aggravating to
deal with and i wish we had more
predator boss encounters instead of
these guys to deal with and they're not
nearly as memorable as the working joes
in alien isolation [ __ ] them alright so
after a lackluster story mode you end up
in the underground pyramid for the final
encounter and who could that final boss
be
i want you to guess
in this aliens vs predator game what the
final boss is who do you fight in the
big explosive finale
could it be the alien
could be the predator
no you fool it as i ps3 era graphics
lance hendricks hidden with a shotgun
so you find out that he's a bishop
android that was programmed with the
memories of the original weyland and
went out into space to keep excavating
predator [ __ ] for corporate profits
even though human weyland in the movie
was kind of a nice guy and really just
got a bit too ambitious for his britches
because he wanted to do something
impressive before his lung cancer took
him down his simon jarrett over here is
a ruthless bad guy for some reason and
so is the next one because even after
you make him go the way of the t2 he has
a backup wayland ready to sequel bait us
it's everything we'd hoped
worth waiting centuries for
the coordinates to the xenomorph
homeworld
wow that'd be pretty exciting if uh
if this got a sequel add yet another
bishop to the endless ranks of them
spread across this franchise
now for the other two campaigns the
predator's gameplay is kind of cool in
concept but once again executed somewhat
awkwardly i don't really vibe with the
first person perspective just because
mobility is so much more limited now
jumping around from treetop to treetop
seems like it'd be a little barf
inducing for some people the basic
mechanics are all here for the predator
to put at you can turn invisible charge
from batteries to get more energy lure
marine npcs around with the voice
distraction and blast them with various
weapons concrete jungle would have
definitely benefited from a weapon wheel
like this instead of that slow horrible
menu [ __ ] you play as a different
predator who runs around through the
same levels as the marines in a
different order hunting down soldiers in
various stealth segments destroying
bodies of predators who weren't as cool
and handsome as you and collecting
ancient predator tech that'll make you
more proficient at literal head hunting
even though the traversal was a little
uncomfortable at the start i eventually
got used to it and had a lot of fun
stealthing around and doing my best
sub-zero impression with all these space
marines it reminded me of arkham style
stealth segments where you're
distracting guys picking them off with
stealth takedowns and hearing a voice
over the intercom asking gerald over
there if his spine is still connected
god damn this is pretty gory
once again i wish that we could have had
a predator game with the gameplay style
of hunting grounds and the story of
concrete jungle but maybe with the
stealth encounter layouts of this game
on top of them it's also nice to be able
to sneak past enemies at times and skip
whole fights on your way to more
important objectives things get a bit
clunkier though when you have to fight
aliens because they're so fast and
you're so
big and lumbering the first person
brawling with your wrist blades feels
stiff as hell and wasn't really fun so i
went out of my way to avoid it typically
the only unique boss fight in this
campaign is the good old pred alien who
for some reason has super strength and
can ground pounds so hard it makes the
level layout change like he's a god of
war boss much like all other bosses in
this game however he's a bit of a
pushover all you gotta do is get into a
good combo of pokes and stabs with the
wrist blades and he eventually goes down
conceptually the pred alien is cool but
every time we've seen it it's been
utilized in such lame ways i can't get
over it the story is pretty basic and
underdeveloped in this campaign because
they like to keep the predators
themselves mysterious so having any of
them be characters or explaining their
culture or motivations more clearly
would ruin the mystique of them
so there's not a lot to go off of you
collect armor and gadgets from some
legendary super badass predator from a
long time ago that everyone loves and
then use those gadgets and weapons to
blow up the temple and head on home
you thought the motion sickness was bad
before alien time [ __ ]
you play as one of the aliens being
harvested for weyland yutani's
experiments a special little guy named
number six with a tattoo to that effect
you're an adorable friendly space cutie
who loves to play with everyone you
encounter and do cool spider-man [ __ ] if
you think about it spider-man is 40
xenomorph because he can climb on walls
and when he mates with someone they also
die the movement on walls is very
disorienting at first sometimes i'll
accidentally walk on a wall and my
spatial awareness will get totally
thrown off leading to me getting blasted
by these buster-ass humans sometimes if
you need to crawl around in a very
confined area you might end up
accidentally walking on the ceiling and
floor without even trying come on i'm
just trying to turn a corner here
jesus i feel like i'm in a spin cycle
i'm gonna throw up
i do however like the tail attacks and
the smashing of light bulbs to hide
yourself that feels like a really direct
inspiration from the darkness with your
bladed tentacles breaking the fixtures
to make the game harder to see however
your vision always adjusts to the dark
and you have a great sense of your
surroundings with the ability to sense
humans through walls i also like that
you can slowly put a facehugger on
people as a finishing move that's scary
and [ __ ] up there's not as much to
talk about with this one number six runs
around killing humans and a handful of
predators then evolves into a big queen
and we sure do love her this is by far
the shortest campaign
and weirdly i like that about it i think
i may actually not like this game
overall the campaigns in this game are a
little short and underwhelming on their
own playing them all back to back may
get a little dull because you're just
running through the same levels but at
least you get to see them from a new
perspective each time because each
character plays so differently and
admittedly the multiplayer for this game
is still pretty fun if you have enough
people to fill a server here's some
highlights of that
people let me tell you about my best
friend
is it always this dark as a oh there's
my friend predator
is that you xavier right there okay i'm
uh how do how do i spray predator did
you see those two predators run up on me
and i beat their ass that was great oh
we should that is some big dick stuff
oh behind us a team here oh [ __ ]
oh my god i got it
i think this might just be death
as in everyone's an enemy
everyone's an enemy
really oh
so fast to turn on me
i saw xavier slowly face me i was like
what are you doing
the auto turkey kept
there's a predator in me
good times now back to you diego thanks
xavier oh oh [ __ ] i have two in a row
that hasn't happened in ages um
okay so uh mortal kombat is a series
that i haven't talked about in a while
because no one watched my review of
armageddon
uh but um
i should have had a script prepared
cyrax sector and smoke are very
obviously based on the predator visually
so fans spent decades wondering what
it'd be like if the real deal got to be
in the game alongside them
and seeing as how mortal kombat's newest
trilogy slowly turned into smash bros
but with 80s characters the opportunity
finally arrived
now there's two armored badasses with
dreadlocks that can do horrible things
to your rib cage but hey you can't have
chocolate without a little peanut butter
so they tossed in a xenomorph that
spawned from baraka that's a pretty
clever workaround for giving the alien a
more muscular superhero physique to fit
the game's preset animations because the
normal alien is too much of a weird
lanky dog skeleton thing and it'd be
strange to see someone fighting it hand
to hand plus he's got baraka blades for
a few extra moves because he's a tar
cotton hybrid that's neato both of them
have some pretty creative and on-brand
fatalities i like how the baby alien
looks like an alien version of whatever
it's growing in including having a tiny
jason mask or even being a predalien
while it's unfortunate that the
indecipherable black screen with sound
effects that was requiem managed to kill
this franchise so definitively by its
awfulness avp still lives on in our
hearts and in crossovers with other
brands between this and broforce and
fortnite aliens and predators can still
be seen in mainstream games kicking each
other's asses and i suspect we'll see a
more proper crossover with them again
sometime soon
did someone say bro force
[Applause]
[Music]
broforce is the video game equivalent of
me being sneaky about getting unlicensed
music in my videos by just talking
loudly over it not having a ton of
spaces between my sentences you can't
get sued for copyright infringement if
you change their name to bro something
and give them a slightly different belt
and as such dozens of muscular 80s
action heroes come together in this
chaotic side-scroller shooter every time
you rescued another character from these
cages you get to play as them with an
extra life after hitting a certain
number of rescues you unlock new
characters such as pretty bro and ellen
rip bro these names are obviously
nowhere near as perfect as brobo cop but
damn it they tried you eventually unlock
a level called alien pheromones where
you play as ripley shooting her way
through a legally distinct alien hives
with various types of not xenomorph
enemies you can even get face hugged as
a death animation there's also flying
aliens that explode into acid when they
hit you and obviously the standard one
aliens being a one hit kill feels kinda
right to me you're just too dangerous to
have an extended grapple with unless
you're a super powered mortal combat
character
however you can also battle aliens as
the predator assuming you don't die as
soon as you spawn as him
when you get a chance to play as the
predator he can use his trusty glaive to
make platforms or pin enemies to walls
so they can stick around
his special ability is to turn invisible
and use his plasma caster to clear the
screen of enemies
i bro tired of this endless prattle
my ceaseless effort and professionalism
is never reciprocated by the likes of
the proletariat
[Music]
that would have been a lot cooler if i
could have seen what it looked like
while it was still alive
more ancient technology
since the radio is dead
maybe we can use this to signal for
backup
before the comments complained this was
my phone at one point i'm not that young
well you better figure it out fast
mobile games lightning round
avp combat evolved my third favorite
game after avp modern warfare and avp
revengeance it's a carbon copy of
rampage with digitized graphics where
the alien and predator have giant heads
and little bodies but they also have
giant everything because here's a normal
human for scale
why are they so big who saw alien and
predator and thought hey here's a good
game style we could apply them to
literally anything would have worked
better for this except maybe a kart
racer so you might as well have just
done pac-man oh wait evp 2004 it's like
a side scroller where you're in the
pyramid from the movie i guess and it
looks awful just the worst i bet one
single person in the audience remembers
playing it when they were like two years
old and will cuss me out in the comments
because it's secretly the best game ever
like usual whatever shut the hell up i
don't care you avp 2004
also i can't this is from the same
developers i think uh the footage
for these is so uncommon but this one's
like a pseudo rail shooter or something
it has 3d graphics so that's impressive
for a flip phone i suppose avp requiem
it's a top-down hack and slash i guess
where you're an alien running around
killing stuff we couldn't find something
more interesting than the video on i
wish there was something like a new game
or something we could talk about this is
really lame well i got one more mobile
game for you in 2013 avp evolution was
released for ios and android devices
mobile games have a bad reputation being
known for plaguing your screen with ads
trying to nickel and dime you every time
you open the app and they also tend to
have a really shallow gameplay loop
marvel games but evolution is a totally
valid third person action game it's like
a better version of adp requiem because
not only does combat feel better but you
also get to play as the alien i think
this might be the only game that lets
you play as the alien in this
perspective say fortnite there's a bunch
of upgrades and customization options to
unlock you can even play as the pred
alien
if you bought him before the game was
delisted
yeah it's another one of those
situations this game had a couple of
cool features when it was up on digital
marketplaces like giving players the
ability to record gameplay clips and use
their phone's built-in camera to add
commentary you can then upload those
clips to a social hub but if you try to
do that now you'll just get this sad
message
ah
the story has some cool ideas super
predators are seeking to control
xenomorphs by capturing the alien queen
they're also taking out the lesser
regular jungle hunters because they're a
bunch of [ __ ] and think they're hot
[ __ ] i like this concept because not
only do we get the expected battles of
xenomorphs versus marines predators vs
marines and of course the title of the
[ __ ] game but also cool matchups like
predator vs super predator and alien vs
mind controlled aliens at the end of the
game the predator slays the alien queen
and stops the super predators from
enslaving the xenomorph species the
alien takes out the super predator but
not before attaching a facehugger to its
ugly mug
resulting in the birth of a new hybrid
unique to this game the berserker
xenomorph sick
avp evolution is not a great game it
suffers from repetitive gameplay and
levels that look identical and of course
touch screen controls and 3d games are a
damn nightmare but there are a couple of
decent boss fights and some set pieces
to spice things up a bit it was only
three or four dollars at the time of its
release and i see some genuine effort
here at the time of this recording this
is the latest avp game and it sucks that
it's been delisted from marketplaces but
hey you can play it on the ouya if you
have one of those and you thought the
atari jaguar was gonna be the most
obscure console to show up in this video
ooh
yeah
support for this hunk of crap ended in
2019
well battery's dead
what
that was like three minutes
yep maybe the challenge was finding bars
in the corner we're running low on
rounds and there's still a lot of space
bugs down here
what do we do now cowering under a desk
usually
helps wait that's it
dubious licensing issues those online
servers were hanging on by thread
all we had to do was wait for both
franchises to fall into limbo because of
licensing and legal battles
time eventually does destroy all 80s
horror characters oops sorry
wait no
aliens fireteam available now review
coming soon
[Music]
you